[Musique]
les sirènes retentissent dans le ciel de
Kiev
un missile russe est alors abattu par la
défense aérienne de la capitale
ukrainienne des débris atterrissent sur
un hôpital pour enfants sans faire ni
blesser ni des gaz importants
ce vendredi matin plusieurs autres
explosions ont retenti dans le centre et
l'ouest du pays à plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres du front selon l'armée
ukrainienne 4 missiles hypersoniques
qu'on notamment été tirés vers la région
occidentale
divanofranchiska la matinée a commencé
par une alerte aérienne des
infrastructures civiles ont été frappées
il y a des victimes dont un enfant qui
était transféré à l'hôpital les médecins
ont fait tout leur possible
malheureusement sa vie n'a pas pu être
sauvée
à plus de 1300 kilomètres de là c'est un
drone ukrainien qui est abattu au-dessus
d'un faubourg de l'ouest de Moscou en
début de matinée
[Musique]
il y a eu une énorme explosion
incroyable le tarmac a tremblé
le maire de la capitale russe a indiqué
que le drone s'est écrasé dans un parc
forestier près d'un hôpital sans faire
de dégâts importants
il y a une explosion un bruit très fort
et de la fumée noire bien sûr que j'ai
peur j'ai trois enfants bien sûr que je
suis inquiet ça se passe à côté de chez
nous
c'est la troisième fois cette semaine
que des drones s'abattent au dessus de
Moscou les attaques sur le territoire
russe se multiplient ces dernières
semaines le plus souvent sans dégâts ni
victime
fin juillet des drones avaient été
abattu au-dessus d'un quartier
d'affaires de la capitale russe tandis
qu'en mai dernier deux drones étaient
interceptés au-dessus du Kremlin